well
cardi b is getting that press thanks to
an 88 thousand dollar purse
and some pretty intense backlash oh
snappity snap snap
it all started on sunday when the wap
rapper tweeted asking her followers if
she should splurge on a new bag
the price tag a whopping 88 grand
oh yes honey well that tweet didn't sit
well with some people
you know since we're in the middle of a
global pandemic and an economic crisis
and all
it could be always a hit or miss one
twitter user wrote
yes girl people commenting who haven't
eaten yet today because they're broke
another added quote it just speaks to
your privilege that you could spend
that much on a handbag that's more than
most people make in a year
while another fan urged her to read the
room but cardi wasn't about to take the
heat lying down
[Music]
she quickly reminded people that she had
donated two various coveted relief
causes throughout the year
and doubled down tweeting quote also i
got seven uncles and three aunts on my
daddy's side
nine aunts and three uncles on my mama
side a whole bunch of cousins i had to
help because of the pandemic
if i want to splurge i can without y'all
asking for handouts like me and my
husband don't do so
thank you yeah that didn't exactly shut
down the hate
so the 28 year old set up a challenge
quote since you want to tell me to
donate so much drop receipts on what you
have donated too
i will match it and donate to an
organization you have donate as well
let's start now and just in case that
wasn't enough
she tweeted an apology sort of okay guys
i apologize
there you happy i don't see you asking
trump for an apology when he out here
missing coveted meetings to play golf
as for that 88 000 bag yeah
she went ahead and bought it tweeting
quote so
do you want me to show you the purse i
gotta see it to believe it